follow me if you will down a rabbit hole
where something comes out and then I
criticize that thing and then someone
criticizes me for criticizing that thing
and I criticize someone for criticizing
me for criticizing that thing are you
following me because that's the internet
baby that's where we are and that's
what's happened in this case with a
little caveat
there's a gal by the name of queer kiwi
and queer kiwi primarily makes content
criticizing other people so now I'm
going to criticize her criticism this
video is brought to you by genius I'll
more from them in a second first let's
take it away with queer kiwi when
somebody has sex they are risking
procreation so the two are obviously
intertwined creating a new human life is
so amazing not if you don't have
resources not if you don't have money
not everyone is going to be in a
situation where they ever feel prepared
to bring a child into this world and I
think that that is something that needs
to be respected and those people deserve
to be able to have sex so she's right in
that
having children is not for everybody
humans broadly are called to be fruitful
and multiply but some people are called
to consecrated religious life some
people are called too consecrated
singlehood some people are called to be
celibate no no I'm abstinent this is
but then where she goes wrong and she
says and people should be entitled to
sex without having to risk having a baby
why is that where do you find that
entitlement where do you find that risk
things have purpose the purpose of sex
is procreation that's what it's for yes
sex is pleasurable yes sex is a fine way
to pass the time yes sex can do all
sorts of things that's what she said
passive sex is to have a child and so
when you divorce a thing from its
purpose then you get into real thorny
moral dilemmas and problems and Grave
mortal sin look I want to have sex and
so I'm going to do it and I don't want
to deal with the consequences and if a
baby comes about as a result I want to
kill the baby and I'm going to try to
avoid having the baby with contraception
or whatever but me me me want want well
that's not a moral argument what if
people chose not to have sex until they
were in a relationship publicly with
someone they were committed to for life
and prepared to have children that might
come from that we'd have a lot less
murdered babies not everyone who is in
long-term committed relationships want
to have kids not everyone will ever be
prepared to have kids there is a greater
risk of getting into a car crash when
you get into a cop and that is of
getting pregnant while using birth
control so like are you gonna tell
someone who gets into a car crash like
this is your fault you got into a car so
like no you're not gonna blame them
you're going to offer them Medical Care
and help them through it because that's
a traumatizing thing but is it immoral
to get in a car in most circumstances no
is it immoral to engage in sex outside
of marriage that is not open to life the
result of which might be to kill a child
yes that is immoral so it's not not a
great comparison just like the fetuses
Chuck I wasn't born yesterday either and
having a baby when you're not ready for
a baby not only has negative
consequences and impacts you negatively
but it also does for that child too and
are you going to provide it with care
once it is blonde no you're gonna murder
it instead that's so much better for the
baby right it's a girl
no it's really compassionate for you to
murder a poor defenseless innocent baby
if you allow that baby to live you might
not be the best mother ever better to
murder him that's really compassionate
right
right are you going to give that parent
those parents are you going to give them
the support and the funds that they need
in order to raise uh just statistically
yes that is what happens the people who
are pro-life the people are conservative
give much more money to charity than the
liberals do there were some 36 couples
who are trying to adopt every newborn
baby in the United States put up for
adoption this argument from the
pro-abortion side is sober one well if
you don't think we should murder babies
are you willing to support the babies
yeah
you have as many resources as you want
give me a call I will direct you to some
resources so you don't actually care
about the child because maybe they're
going to grow up being very traumatized
maybe they're going to have a really
life that they don't particularly want
because they were forced to be born that
girl was forced to be born oh that
Michael I hate him he's just so smug
we're all forced to be born should we be
able to murder any baby we like and
somebody who talks like you deserves to
be locked in a hot car with the windows
rolled up oh my God
I'm gonna toast your child I don't think
that Mademoiselle kiwi here believes
that we should be able to murder any
baby we like or any newborn baby or any
baby we find across the street no man
was lucky we would probably call this a
great crime but for some reason when
it's the mother that's fine why is it
only better for some people to exist but
not for other people to exist why is it
good for Mademoiselle kiwi to exist but
not for the innocent vulnerable little
baby life is better than death we all
know that to be the case we all prove it
with every breath that we take we don't
off ourselves we don't kill ourselves
even the people who promote abortion
even the people who whine about
overpopulation and promote assisted
suicide of the elderly and the poor
those people are never volunteering
they're never the ones who say okay off
me now and good thank God they don't do
that but then it proves the point life
is better than death it's just that some
people want life for themselves and they
want to deprive other people of the
privilege and right to life right now go
to geniusell.com knowlesyt did you know
our friends at geniusell have upgraded
their most popular package to feature
their top selling deep firming vitamin C
theorem plus Ultra retinol moisturizer
with natural retinol alternative right
now you can take advantage of this
limited time package upgrade for 70
percent off 7-0 why waste time and money
to get work done to your face when you
can get geniusell skin care shipped
straight to your door here is a
geniusell.com review from Robert and
blessing Texas quote I purchased Jenny
sells a gift for my girlfriend she said
she saw results so fast her skin is
noticeably softer and smoother I can see
and feel a difference too she was
already beautiful and geniusell has made
her more beautiful geniusell secret is a
family recipe for over 20 years that
makes it safe for all skin types and
perfect for both men and women it's made
by a compounding pharmacist and small
batch is always safe cruelty free and
natural the founder of this company
great guy Coptic Christian from Egypt
left for the American dream head on over
to geniusell.com Knowles YT letter y
letter T try Jenny cell's most popular
package for seventy seven zero percent
off featuring both genusal's Ultra
retinol and Geniuses Firming Serum in a
complimentary spot Essentials box with
every package order plus free upgrade to
Prime already shipping genucel.com
knowlesyt geniusell.com Knowles YT okay
give me more kiwi I've actually already
successfully induced lactation like I
can actually make milk now
which has been a a very a very
interesting and very cool experience
it's like very biologically affirming
too which is something that's like gay
kept from women like so so difficult
you see what I mean about the editing of
this like I'm gonna need you to tell me
where the problem lies and what's
off-putting about this oh I'll tell you
I'll happily tell you it's grotesque
disgusting we know that lactation is not
what that man's male body is for if a
woman were sitting there talking about
breastfeeding it might occasionally make
some men a little squeamish got milk
all right but men are not for that it's
not what the male chest is for when I
have these hulking pectoral muscles you
know my big massive pecs like the rest
of my Adonis muscles okay they're for a
purpose and that purpose is not a
suckling babe it's why in order to make
it happen you have to inject the man
with a bunch of hormones and chemicals
and poison to try to trick the body into
producing a kind of a fluid that is not
been tested to be safe for babies and
that is being recklessly given to babies
that somehow this man has come into
possession of for no other reason than
to affirm his own disordered desires not
for the good of the baby but what this
new ideology does is flips that on its
head she is producing breast milk
like that's all it is so I think it's
really cool that they have like you know
started uh applying this and using like
hormone therapy and whatnot to help
women and like nonvi
non-bi parent produced breast milk to
feed their babies there's no evidence
that that's good for the man there's
also no evidence that any of this is
good for the baby at all but that's a
total afterthought and that's another
piece of evidence that what you're
engaging in is maybe not the right way
of looking at things modern culture
tells us deny your revulsions deny that
actually you you should seek out things
that are revolting because Prejudice is
a wonderful thing
sometimes it can be unjust but we all
prejudge we all that we couldn't get out
of bed in the morning if we didn't just
go by our gut rather than by rational
analysis every single time in your gut
usually is right very often it's more
correct than even the poultry stack of
reason you've got floating between your
ears a lot of people struggle to lactate
and so there are procedures that can be
done and steps that can be taken in
order to help you do that and so they're
using a practice that is used for CIS
women just full of women and it's like
it's the same thing
it's just like food for our baby you're
just helping yourself create that so you
can have an intimate like parental there
it is and it's about you and it's about
you having this feeling of intimacy that
you're not meant to have because you're
not the kind of person for whom that
intimacy is intended if you're a man you
can have all sorts of intimacy with your
baby you can rock your baby you can stay
up at night with your baby when the
baby's crying but you're not supposed to
breastfeed your baby that's not what
you're for and when you put your own
disordered desires above nature and
above the way things are supposed to be
things can go awry so maybe if we just
trusted our guts a little bit more or
supposedly enlightened rational Society
wouldn't be so irrational as it is today
all right I guess my producer invited Ms
kiwi on unbeknownst to me apparently she
declined our invitation but she's more
than welcome to come on I would love to
love to have a chat with uh with Miss
kiwi
I'll be watching you
[Music]